hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today I'm
streaming from home I had some issues
with the quality but then I turned off
Spotify the the desktop player and that
seemed to fix the issues but if you have
any issues let me know I'll do what I
can see sorry I just I just saw the the
quality drop so I was just making sure
like alright what else can I shut down
here let me shed some more tabs and in
chrome I thought I shot all of them down
but then I noticed that on one of my
other screens I still had some of them
up that I really didn't need let's see
alright it's pretty good
okay cool
so if you weren't here yesterday I'm
gonna just go over briefly what we did
because we're just gonna continue on
with what we started yesterday so this
will probably be best if you can see the
code or an example so I'm gonna switch
over so you can see the code and let's
start with an example I think that'll be
best for now so here in the side menu we
have sections and you can drop down
these sections and see you know these
lengths underneath here what I'd like to
do though is make it so that these links
inside of a section could also be
dropdowns and have their own submenu
items so yesterday we did a few things
but what we ended with was that we
divided up these links into having the
link on the left side and then we have
the section over here on the right side
when you click it right now nothing
happens right so we had we wanted to
leave it so that this side could still
be a link
oops and then the other side I don't
know why that's just close I guess I
accidentally clicked on something so
then the other side would be an icon to
indicate that you can drop down and have
some more some more options so I've
changed some of the data it's
add it in let me make that bigger
there's no way you can see that there we
are you don't need that for right now
okay so in our data and for those of you
who are new you can check out all this
code online the link to the github repo
is in the description below this video
so right now we're in draw menu jas and
we've added about of these sub menu
items if you remember yesterday we were
just saying sub menu true if we wanted a
sub menu now we have an array of objects
that will have the text the link URL and
then the as URL if this looks weird to
you
it is weird you don't normally have to
include this but to keep the client-side
routing working like we want it to we
have to add this in so now we actually
have some data we can go back into our
component and we can map over this data
and try to put in some some links so
let's do that now so we won't really
need to come back to this data we're
gonna be in sewer component is
so we're gonna be in the components
folder and we're gonna select drawer
item J s so if you would like to check
out the code that's where it's gonna be
and so here's where where we're at if
you remember from from yesterday
actually let me start my poem a tour o
clock so we can get started on on some
of this coding yesterday we added in an
option where we had our set menu items
so before we were just saying let's see
if there are sub menu items then we want
to render this collapsible section and
then within there we were mapping over
all the sub menu items and that data
came from you know this this page that
we have open over here this file and
then we were displaying all of those
links but now we added in an alternative
so if that particular item has sub menu
items so even more sub another sub menu
inside of the item that is the sub menu
so I guess that's a bit confusing but
essentially we're having like two levels
of Link's possible here then we were
going to add in and yesterday all the
farther we got was we added in another
section where an icon could live that
would be clickable what we need to do
today is actually make add in the icon
make it clickable and then when it's
clicked
we want to be able to display a whole
other collapsible section so it's it's
gonna get a little bit tricky but I
think I think we can get through it
today and today stream givin you know
maybe like two to pomodoro sessions
sorry I just got messages from my work
slack so I was just double-checking to
make sure it wasn't an emergency okay
let's see so I guess first thing we
should do then is just just go for the
icon so a first step is let's actually
display an icon second step is set up a
click handler for that and then after
that we'll worry about displaying the
submenu items so here we're just we're
saying submenu that's not what we want
right we want this click so let's see
how we're doing this here
okay so we already have these expand
more expand last icons so let's grab
this for now and we'll put it down here
and let's see you want to say is alright
this looks weird but it's gonna say is
sub sub menu open I mean I'm not sure
how to say that but it is a sub menu
inside a sub menu so let's make sure we
add that to our you know what we're
gonna have to go up are we gonna have to
go up let me think
no we won't
so I think were we're handling we're
handling a lot of these in in the parent
component but I don't think we would
need to
I don't think we need to do that all
right let me know if anybody thinks
otherwise but I don't think there's any
reason why we need to move this up to
the parent component see do we need it
no we don't I remember now why we end up
moving that because on the click of a of
these links we wanted to be able to open
up a section so we needed to handle that
in a parent component so that basically
we could change the state by clicking on
something in this app bar component and
then that state could be passed down so
that's why we did it so we don't need to
worry about that so let's add in some
state actually we could probably copy a
lot of what we did for the component for
the other component in here so let's do
that I was like I think we did this in
layout so let's copy this is copy all
the state from layout for now and then
we'll remove what we need to remove
okay
[Music]
okay yeah this should work
so first let's copy that actually oh I
thought I could copy it all in one go
but this is for the drawer so let's go
back okay so we don't need this drawer I
don't know that we need this either
let's see this expand item we will need
this so let's copy this and move to
floor item and right now I'm just
copying as we go through I'll explain
more of what these do because you know
we we did this a long time ago so many
of you have joined the stream you know
even with the letter within the last
month or so probably won't remember how
we did this so essentially we are
getting the previous state and we're
changing it to basically like the
opposite of the previous state for the
drawer item so if it that's all I mean
it may look like a little more than you
need for that but that's essentially
what we're doing is we're changing the
the drawer item basically from like open
to closed right I mean really you know
pretty simple so let's go see that'll be
passed this in yeah it's gonna be a
little it is going to be a bit simpler
because you see here
we passed in two drawer this expand item
and then in drawer see real estate
so I'm trying to find I'm just trying to
take you through the flow of this and
see where it it's a all right so we're
below this okay so here's where we have
our drawer item okay and this is where
we're passing down that expand item and
we're also passing down the states to
say whether or not this is open so it's
this props drawer item or items about
okay and if you remember we actually we
had in the state for the app bar or I'm
sorry for the layout in state there was
an option in state called drawer items
and then about was inside that so we had
that for you know for each one of these
we actually hard-coded these in since
there's so few of them okay if we get
many more than this will probably just
map over the data stored somewhere else
to save some space I mean that that's
just those ones alone are probably
taking up 1/4 of this component right
now so we may end up doing that to save
some space but not not for this stream
right now okay and then finally we get
to draw them we can see that that expand
item and is open is also getting passed
down so we see is open determines which
[Music]
sorry
it determines which icon that's the way
I was looking for is gonna be displayed
so in this case do we want some minute
okay
I just broke it because I I was in the
middle of changing this so we won't be
able to see it yet so basically is like
is the the little arrow pointing up or
down right that's that's what this was
will do and if
let's see there are some menu items then
we're gonna actually add all this you
know collapse tough for the the list see
and actually for this where there's some
minions yet for this one there are
submenu items for everything which is
why we didn't really bother to add an
alternative because that top level
always has it
so that's but inside of here we need
another option so inside of here we've
essentially done the same thing we're
checking for submenu items or I'm sorry
we're checking for submenu on the
submenu items but we're having two
options so we've already moved this
expand more expand less down here and
that's why we've created that is sub
submenu okay that was a longer
explanation that I anticipated but
essentially like that's that's what we
want so let's go with the state and say
[Music]
okay yeah we're not gonna have we're
actually not gonna need these right
yeah we're I don't think we will need
any drawer items yeah essentially I
don't want to hard-code this there's
gonna be way too many so that's what I'm
saying like we don't really need drawer
items I will put in like hey we you know
we do have this but right now there's
nothing in it so then what will happen
is this will get added in so we'll
probably need to rework this a bit
all right actually will we'll see if
this automatically adds it in because
this is within says state that's the
behavior that I want is to automatically
add add that in I'm gonna check my time
okay ten minutes all right so we should
have time to get basically to see
something also whatever I want I totally
forgot to add his sub sub menu open so
we're gonna need
let me think actually we're gonna need
to pass this you'll need this
whoops and I didn't get everything
it's we'll need that and let's put it
here on the grid item itself to give a
bigger click area so ID let's make sure
yeah there we go expand item item ID and
then what we'll want here is I think
we're we're not gonna do a sub sub menu
open what we'll do is we'll say drawer
and I can remember it was those two
items dots or will draw items and then
we'll say item ID droid um's
item ID and then we're gonna check to
see no that's it we should be able to
check to see drawer and I'm sorry to my
D so let's go up here where we have this
props and let's also make costs let's
say items
this state okay and what else you want
that's it for now also item ID is not
gonna work for us
these item IDs being passed down so the
item ID in this case would would be
talking about this this kind of upper
level yes let's see so drawer is passing
down item ID and then we're manually
passing down the idea of abouts
so we're not gonna do that what we need
to do instead of item ID is say and this
is only in that that interior that sub
sub menu instead of item ID we need see
what we want to do let's check our data
for a second to see I mean we could use
I suppose we could just use the text
then the item ID will be will be the
text so we'll say item dot dot text
okay
all right wow that was not what I wanted
there we go okay so this will probably
be enough yeah this should be enough to
just see the menu items now and it
should fix any errors that we have so I
think and while that's loading I checked
my time okay about five minutes so make
sure it loads okay good
it's a good sign everything is just so
slow when I stream from home it's just
the you know my MacBook is much less
powerful than my iMac okay so let's go
here see we have yay check it out okay
so we have so this just want to make
sure so it doesn't affect this at all so
our state separate which is expected
that's what you wanted to happen now we
have this whoops you know we're gonna
have to do we we I believe we have it
set to auto close when this is clicked
on so we're gonna have to change that
but other than that I mean this is where
and the alignments a little bit off but
other than that this is working so far
alright so that was you know basically
phase one was get the icon there and
have it only show up if there were
submenu items so now step two is
basically make something happen when
that's clicked on so we're gonna add a
click Handler and right now
actually let's we should check the state
so we should have because we did put the
clickhandler on there so we should have
something happening with the state you
know we're gonna have to take so we have
a on click toggle drawer for these list
items and we actually really don't want
that so for every list everything in the
list
we're toggling the drawer so what we we
don't want that what we want instead we
want to remove these toggles from list
and we want to add these toggles down to
our actual our actual a tag so actually
we do we have the toggle drawn on this a
tag
interesting I think I'm gonna add them
and that I want to add them here to our
link and we should be able to remove
them from the a saying so if you
shouldn't really need it anymore and but
then when we have yeah so this should
work so this is now on the link but not
on our our toggle here but then on this
link let's add it here but not on the a
the a tag okay let's see how that how
that goes let's wait for the refresh
maybe let's manually refresh this will
probably be the last thing we do for
this Pomodoro session then we'll take a
break and only answer some questions in
the live chat okay okay and when I click
this it should not close wonderful but
when I click this it should close
automatically automatically close
okay so I guess I broke it
see we have this going here let's check
this one yeah I have broken that
functionality so we're gonna fix that
when I come back when we come back we'll
do a break now for questions and you
scroll up Phoenix says sorry for not
being here yesterday but as promised I'm
here today
awesome awesome it's good to have you
here Peter says haven't been able to to
kiss the stream in a while how y'all
doing I'm doing okay it's good good to
have you back
Freddie says buenos dias buenos dias
bienvenidos
all right Freddy's this speaking Spanish
and I'm trying to translate but my
Spanish is not great in its here hey Ana
how's it going rooks here hey I might
have to use Google Translate here let me
maybe open Google Translate on my other
screen and then that way I'll know I'll
know for sure what you're saying
okay cool so sis something is learned
everyday
let's see you guys translate the rest
okay so it looks like Freddie sitting
else I'll see you later
it's 1:30 in the afternoon yeah Freddie
I think we're in the tape same timezone
here cuz that's what time it is over
here Phoenix is by the way I bill will
be starting reaction just curious is you
kind of a subset of react so no actually
so view is totally different library
than react so they the end result is
usually the same you know you're you're
gonna build a web app but yeah if you
would reactor are totally different
projects sorry about the yawn yeah so if
you know some concepts I'm sure will be
the same between view and react I
personally have not used you so I can't
tell you for sure you'll with the
biggest differences are and similarities
but yeah you I mean if you know react
you're not gonna automatically know view
so they're not they're not that you know
close together
and it says any plans for tomorrow
tomorrow Thursday I'll be in the office
tomorrow just have a meeting and I think
that's it I don't have any anything else
planned just gonna meeting I'm hopefully
gonna do a stream and just just work on
this work on this website some more and
then of course hang out with my family
afterwards but alright so those good
timing I get to the bottom of the chat
here we go John ask one more question I
have a strange chrome problem only on my
own create reacts create react apps I
can no longer edit any styles in the dev
tools all of them are grayed out style
editing works in Firefox and edge anyone
Wow I have never heard of that happening
so I mean if anyone just come across
that issue please let us know in the
chat or in the comments of this video
yeah I've never had that I have it I
don't know why it would be doing that
well actually I don't know what's going
on today but we have a lot less viewers
than normal which is actually cool it's
kind of like more chill when when we do
it like this I feel like I have kind of
freedom to spend more time on each
question and in talking to you all
individually but yeah I wonder what
happened what happened is anything else
going on like live right now or I don't
know usually when this happens it's
because like notifications didn't go out
to people so that's a possibility I
think I did do a stream during like some
big conference that was live streaming
or and I didn't get a lot of people then
Oh
Ricardo says Zuckerberg at at Congress
yeah all right I didn't realize that was
still going on right now so if that's
the case that that probably explains it
I'm gonna go with that and not like
nobody wants to watch my show so if they
pick Mark Zuckerberg over me then I'll
understand that that's acceptable
all right so started the next Pomodoro
timer we'll do one more and I have just
broken something that was working on
this component so we did have it
automatically shut the drawer when you
clicked on one of these links now it's
not working so let's figure out why it
broke and try to get that that working
and then we can move on you know to the
to the next part okay so what I did was
I removed actually this is interesting
maybe that's so obviously this does not
work on the link tag itself maybe it it
should be on the a tag which we removed
it from the a tag well yeah there we go
okay so maybe it should be on the a tag
and so we're gonna put it back on the a
tag and for this one and we're gonna do
the same thing here for this a tag and
we're gonna go ahead and remove it from
these links since obviously it's not
working on those links those link tags
now we also removed it from the list I
hope that it's not necessary to have it
there
we'll see I'm under fresh so it will
Auto refresh eventually it's supposed to
but everything's running so slowly I'm
just gonna refresh myself you think that
I don't really I really like my my
MacBook Pro but one of the things I
don't like is the inability to upgrade
it you know very very much beyond what
you get so it would be nice if I could
just keep this same MacBook and then add
more to it you know but at least the
last time I checked I didn't think that
was possible to do it's still not
working
that's to add all right so let's let's
look a little deeper and see if we can
figure out why it's not working all
right so on clique we want a toggle
drawer why would it be working only
sometimes
now well maybe we need to move it
further up then let's take it from here
and let's move it up to our grid item
and see if that works I guess we could
do the same here whoops now I guess we
can't do the same here because we have
[Music]
we don't have a grid do we have the lane
oh that's right yeah we didn't make
these a great item all right well let's
just test it out I'm not really hopeful
that this will work
hey alright so that worked for this one
so when we click undergraduate great
that worked but when we click graduate
that didn't work so let's you know what
let's move this back here let's move
this back onto the link and double check
to make sure that was not working and if
we need to we can just wrap this in a
div and then that may work so we'll wrap
it in a div and then put the on clicking
on key down into the div we'll see
her Kurtis is also Champions League
quarter-finals live oh I mean I'm I'm up
against Mark Zuckerberg Congress and
Champions League so I mean I'd say I'm
doing pretty pretty good with the 17
viewers that are here right now so for
those of you that are watching thank you
very much for choosing me over all that
other stuff alright let's see in the
show nope all right let's make a div
let's get rid of this let's make it is
this in the dude
save that
refresh
there we are that works let me click on
another link though to make sure that
[Music]
we're actually getting like the link
part of it's actually working still okay
and it is so the on click on that div to
do the drawer works and then the the
actual link works wonderful alright
great so now so we have the two separate
areas a click on the link part closes
the drawer and the link works but a
click on the icon part does not close
the drawer and it does not cause a
change in the page great so that's what
we want so now we do need here is like
this expand item item text ok let's we
were gonna check to see what's going on
with state so let's go into react open
this every one of these will work
[Music]
this is just like nothing's working is
so slow
let me refresh if I get it working again
all right know what let's just do it
this way you know what I bet I'm calling
this all right so let's say expand
sub-item and let's change this to expand
sub-item
and I'm not saying my goodness this the
I have made so many mistakes in here
what is I don't know it co that was
wrong with that when I first copied it
over alright anyway let's see what what
this gives us
and it doesn't matter about dev tools
over here this is close that
okay not doing anything for their let's
see drawer items
okay calling this
we're just gonna console.log some stuff
so since our react dev tools are not
doing anything just use old-fashioned
console logs let's make that a bit
bigger see waiting for this load it's
still spinning I think it hasn't loaded
yet yeah this definitely hasn't loaded
yet
whoa lots of stuff up in here he's shiny
key drop okay
okay I will fix this in a second let's
see what we're getting in the console
let's just do it all this stuff okay
okay so this is changing its adding
academically excellent true or false
there we are okay so we are getting a
change now I believe it's just the
extreme lag from me trying to stream and
you know run OBS so there we are that is
working just like we wanted to let's
make sure it works with this other one
as well independently yep it does work
hold on a second no that's not the
behavior that I really want all right
let's go back and check see what what
should be happening here is it shouldn't
be overriding completely the previous
state here so it should keep whatever we
set for the drawer items so what should
happen is that everything that was there
should be combined with this new this
new state just for that particular item
[Music]
I know what I'm doing wrong I mean
obviously it's working but all right sue
said that
I guess it still works
all right I'm yeah I'm not gonna worry
about that I'm gonna leave the console
log in to remind myself that it's not
working exactly as I want so from a user
perspective it is working but I would
rather have that state saved so but for
now we have it working enough that we
can add in this collapse so let's do
this let's add in this collapse and the
list into here so what we'll have see oh
yeah that list this time on this time
all right so a list item is within there
we don't want that
all right so we're putting this after
the list on okay so essentially we can
put this after our link and it should
still work now do we want it after
I guess I'll just try it I'm not sure
where this is gonna work the best I
guess after this and then we need lists
they need to close out this collapse and
then within there we're gonna put these
sweat links actually let's copy the
links as we have them here
since that's that's really how we need
them okay
so within that I'll shoot let's stop
that for a second so there we are so we
need to map over these things first
right so let's do item dot sub menu dot
map yeah that's how we're gonna do it
okay so then we'll do sub item and then
we can return this all right yes but we
need to change everywhere that says item
we made the change to sub item see why
it's still giving me missing key prop
okay
missing key prop let's see Oh cuz I move
the key I just I need to move the key
onto the do there we are
and then I need to do that down here as
well
whoops I smooth the key on to the doof
so when you are putting when you're
mapping over something and you're
inserting multiple elements with react
they each need to have a unique key so
that's that's why we're getting that
error and we're also getting that same
error in the console a few minutes ago
and let's fix it up here as well so we
have our key here on the link but really
we should now put it here on our grid
item since that's the outermost item no
actually it's not our outermost item is
the entire grid the grid container so
that's where we're gonna put it for that
and my timer just went off so hopefully
this works
let's give it a refresh see if it works
if it does work then that's great then
we accomplished what we needed to
there's still the issue of the alignment
of those icons but other than that if
this works we should be should be good
it should be mission accomplished for
today
nope sub menu map is not a function I
don't know something you don't know all
right let's see what we have going on
here I believe that we did have sub menu
items okay no no okay
item dot sub menu yes so if item dot
said oh I know I know what the problem
is we still have that
[Music]
submenus set to true at the top here so
the the datatype that it's expecting is
an array but we were giving it a boolean
so that's why we had the error so let's
try that again
so I'm looking while this is loading I'm
checking the live chat we were talking
about how it's a lower than normal
turnout for today's stream and so number
one there's there's several live events
happening right now that could be that
could be it
Phoenix also says you know a lot of
people were here for this for the CSS
seriously for Actos and see a social
Stanley okay so I think it's because not
a lot of them have been here
continuously for react as in CSS it will
stand alone so yeah maybe the few times
that we did your CSS stuff that was
pretty easy to understand sand alone so
that that does make sense
I did get very like above average
turnout for that okay let's try it oh I
know I don't know what I messed up okay
when you copy and pasting things it's
seems like it's easier to forget what
you need to change so this collapse I'm
trying to say like in is open and that's
there is no is open now for this right
so let's see
it's convenient so instead of is open we
instead want we want to use drawer items
and what we're recalling that
oops no no no I'm editing the wrong one
okay let's get down here to the right
one there we are
so we need draw items and then I don't
Doug it's text okay so this will look in
states for the drawer items and then it
will find the value of the drawer item
that has the key of this particular item
in that list
okay
one more refresh if this doesn't work I
am I'm just gonna go back to the
questions because I think I'm out of
ideas and so I'll have to look up some
stuff
haha Carlo said didn't remember about
the Champions League see you later
Jessie
of course you just kidding alright let's
give it a try now
yay all right cool it works awesome I
don't think any of these links actually
work yet I could try it but I think it's
gonna take us to a page that doesn't
work okay but it was cool it actually
did shut the drawer which is what we
wanted so even though the page does not
work yet that's still still very cool
awesome
all right cool so that works so
basically the only thing that needs to
be done for this to be completely
finished would be just some some
alignment thing so right now I would
want this and you probably see it better
like this so right now it's this is
aligned to the top of the container I'd
want it to the middle so it lines up
with this text and then once we open up
these submenu items you can see the
indentation is all wrong it's actually
at the same level as the the top-level
list items we would want it to be and
then at another level and potentially
even have a lower font weight so that'll
need to be fixed while we're doing that
probably what I'll end up doing is
bumping these back even further to make
space for this other level so
essentially the third level which are
these ones will end up being at this
point and then this will bump back this
will bump back and then that way you'll
have you have this so it should make
space for everything like that and so
that's who excuse me to work on that and
then in turn
the data I will need to go through now
and add in sections to the data so that
we have all those sub menus where we
need them alright so there's only a few
more comments in the in the chat so if
you have a question go ahead and put it
in there now but I'm just going to go
through these last few comments and and
then we're gonna finish up the stream
John says console.log is a game saver
for me even in react
yeah for sure I mean I occasionally I'll
see like a tweet or an article saying
that you you should never use
console.log and I don't know I mean to
me sometimes a really simple debugging
issue just it makes sense to use
something really simple maybe if I knew
more about the other ways to debug maybe
it would be easier for me but you know
throwing in a console log is just it's
so easy and I'm so used to it you know
it definitely yes I would need a good
reason to use something else and it
works
Nikki says find myself also console
logging all the time the chrome debugger
and BS code is so powerful though I
haven't learned to use it yet yeah same
with me I just there's there's so much
in there studio code that I I don't know
how to use I'm learning new stuff about
it all the time mainly from you all
Phoenix says hey Jesse what exactly does
yarn do also do you know any packages
that gives me terminal functionality
within sublime text just like we can see
in there's no studio code here I don't
know of any packages for sublime because
I've never used sublime text so I have
no idea if anybody uses sublime I knows
of a package that will allow you to use
an integrated terminal please let us
know in the chatter in the comments and
then in turn
of yarn yarn does exactly the same thing
that NPM does when it first came out it
was claimed that it could do at least
two things better than NPM one it was
faster and two it came with this lock
file that kept all essentially it it's
gave you greater control over like
exactly what what was going on with all
your your packages right so they would
you would save your lock powder you get
up repo and then everybody else would
use that same Locker
so now NPM also has its own lock file
and it is faster as well so I don't know
if yarn has any advantages now or not
over NPM I just got used to using it
after you know shortly after it came out
and so that's why I still use it Albert
says can you make a react Redux and
firebase website slash portfolio when
you're finished with the series this one
is a bit too much for me usually so
Albert usually what I do is whatever I
have to do for my job so we'll see we'll
see what comes up next I imagine
whatever I do next is probably going to
be less difficult than what I'm doing
now because they're just smaller sites
so we'll see yeah sorry yeah I'm not a
hundred percent sure what my next
project is gonna be but I think it will
be less involved nikki says should also
make the drawer bigger on desktop yeah I
can definitely do that I hadn't thought
about that before but that's that's a
possibility John says it's true Nikki at
large
Media with the percentage can work
better than a set pixel with okay cool
yeah I would I think I'd like to use a
percentage with a max with so I would
never want and somebody using an extra
widescreen I would never want the
sidebar to be like really really big so
maybe I can combine some media queries
with a percentage with and a max width
so like I never wanted to be larger than
like let's say 400 pixels wide and then
percentage-wise as well I would never
want it to take up more than let's say I
don't know 80% of a screen yeah
something like that
which I mean it's pretty crazy that it
would take up 80% but still like I think
so maybe actually I could see a case for
a min a Max and min with off to think
about it but that is a good point so I
mean essentially like I'd never want it
to be below 300 pixels and for probably
not above 400 pixels and then on a
desktop I mean it could reasonably take
up 20% of the screen and at least and be
okay Mobile's tricky
I liked actually I could probably use a
percentage on mobile and that would be
okay so like I never wanted to take up
more than 80% of the screen with the
minimum being at 300 yeah is the
smallest phone screen with is 320 pixels
I think yeah anyway oh uh off to test it
out and think more about that in pixels
so
I mean for now that'll probably be
something that it's like if I can get to
it I will but it's not necessary before
launch because it works as it is
all right cool Phoenix says it's just
like buttons we don't want them to get
squeezed nor blowed up yeah exactly yeah
that's exactly the case it will look it
there has to be this medium thing it'll
look terrible if it's squeezed together
and it'll look terrible if it's too big
so we just got to find the right the
right range that's acceptable okay all
right well I think I'm going to finish
up with the stream now so I've got
through the live chat thank you all so
much for watching and for choosing me
over Mark Zuckerberg and Champions
League really appreciate that I should
be back tomorrow I'll be in the office
tomorrow I do have a meeting in the
morning I don't think I have any other
meetings so I should be good tomorrow
for a stream and I'm not exactly sure
what we'll work on tomorrow so it'll be
a surprise
haha yeah so have a wonderful day thank
you all again for watching super helpful
as always and I will be back tomorrow